the Bavarian Alps a winter destination
for vacationers of all ages numerous
trails give cross-country skiers and
hikers a chance to combine sport with
nature the village of Roop holding just
west of the Austrian border offers
typical southern german architecture and
atmosphere nestled in the foothills of
the Alps it only has a population of
roughly 6400 but quite often tourists
outnumber the local residents that's
because loop holding is home to the
biathlon World Cup it also serves as a
training ground for professional
athletes like ski cross champion Tommy
Fisher
[Music]
as heist builders of miles house in a
picture is worth a thousand words it's
true behind me you'd see lakes in the
summer that are now covered in snow the
ski runs here are sensational you can
ski for hundreds of kilometers you might
even run into a professional on brofist
Butler but amateurs to have the unique
opportunity to train here like
professional athletes with professional
coaches this is the area's biathlon camp
run by former by athlete Fritz Fisher I
[Music]
though big thing is when it's time to
shoot safety is of paramount importance
don't fool around with the rifle the
motto here is safety first the Maha love
technically we practice the skating
technique and then after one hour of
practice everyone has the chance to try
shooting at targets there's a small
competition to give participants an idea
of what it's like for a pro to train
here it's moving squad maken Fisher was
Germany's gold medal by athlete at the
1992 Olympics in France even though he
has retired from competitive sports he
remains active as a coach at his sports
arena the guns are the real deal this is
a small caliber rifle 5.6 millimeter
this is the ammunition he goes here each
magazine carries five rounds safety is a
big issue when we train fighting pierdo
el eden I'm a doctor this is a real gun
so you've always got to keep the bowel
facing forward with the muzzle over the
line the participants range from
students carpenters and ex-athletes to
businessmen and women they all have one
thing in common fun it's just about
having fun yes it's cool part from the
shooting and they're off
the skiers have to complete one lap
before moving on to shooting each gun is
accompanied by a professional coach to
make sure the rules are being followed
and like in a professional biathlon
those who don't hit all the targets are
penalized in this case with squats the
action takes place in relays a whole
round must be completed before the next
member of the team can go this bit of
fun doesn't come cheap a to our camp
session costs 149 euros per person at
the end of the day there is nothing more
enjoyable than a refreshing drink at one
of the a price key huts built in the
traditional log cabin stock they are
strewn all over the valley and remain
open in all seasons
the huts are also a great place to wind
down after a tough round of biathlon
training it was a little tiring but lots
of fun we didn't miss every shot
sometimes we actually hit the target so
it was really enjoyable mountains trails
sports and great weather may group
holding an unforgettable winter
destination